START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE WHERE
ONE DOWN FROM A QUORUM MY VICE
CHAIR UNFORTUNATELY IS STUCK
BEHIND AN ACCIDENT SO HE MAY BE
LATE BUT WE DO HAVE REPUBLICAN
REPRESENTATION SO I FEEL
COMFORTABLE STARTING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE. WE HAVE ONLY ONE
BILL TO CONSIDER THIS MORNING
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
A FEW HOUSEKEEPING ISSUES AS
USUAL- IF ANYONE COMES IN
PLEASE STAY SIX FEET APART WEAR
MASK IF ANYONE CALLS AND- THERE
ARE NO WITNESSES TODAY SO WE
ARE JUST- THERE THERE WERE NO
WITNESSES THAT. THAT WERE
NECESSARY TODAY SO WE ARE JUST.
IF YOU ARE CALLING YOU CAN
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION- AND
THAT'S ALL WE ARE TAKING TODAY
WITH THAT MISS GARCIA DO YOU
WANT TO GO AHEAD AND START. I
CAN'T THINK THANK YOU BUT I WE
GOT TO GET ONE MORE PERSON HERE
IF THERE'S ANYONE ON
APPROPRIATIONS IN THE BUILDING.
IT THE NEXT PERSON HAVE THEN
WILL TAKE ROLE REALLY QUICK AND
THEN WE WILL SHOW THE EMOTIONS
TO THE BILL MISS GARCIA- OKAY
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE
WHICH CREATE EQUITY AND OUR
RATE- CODE BY ELIMINATING THE
EXISTING PUBLIC HEALTH OF A
PROVISION CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE
OF A SHOULD NOT BE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY A HANDFUL OF
STUDIES HAVE FOUND
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER.
FEAR ANXIETY DEPRESSION AND
SEXUAL FUNCTION TO BE
CONSEQUENCES OF MARITAL RAPE.
AMERITAS IS NOT MAKE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF RAPE ANY LESS
SEVERE- WHILE THE CLASSES THAT
WILL NOT BE IN SIGNIFICAN IT'S
A SMALL PRICE TO PAY TO INSURE
THAT ALL VICTIMS ARE TREATED
THE SAME I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU- WILL GO
AHEAD AND TAKE IT TO THE PHONE
LINES IF THERE IS ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB.
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR INTO PARTS OR
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO NOW. ONE AND THEN
ZERO PER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
AND ONE MOMENT MANAGER WE HAVE
TO KEEPING UP THANK YOU. AGAIN
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
I PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
THANK YOU AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS JENNY
HUTCHINSON I AM A SCIENTIST AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF ENOUGH
IS ENOUGH VOTER PROJECT IN
SUPPORT OF THIS HELPS THANK
YOU- BEFORE YOU GO TO ANOTHER
PHONE LINE LET'S LET'S
ESTABLISH QUORUM REALLY QUICKLY
PLEASE. MA'AM SECRETARY. SORRY
JESSE GONZALEZ PRESIDENT
BIGELOW CALDERON RIO TELL DALY
DAVIES FONG GABRIEL. IT WATER
GARCIA. LEVINE QUIRK YEAH
ROBERT RIVAS WEBER. VACANCIES
MCCARTY IN BERMAN. GREAT AND I
SAW WE HAD A MOTION BY MISTAKE
HE'S A SECOND BY MISS CARILLO
WITH THAT WE'LL WE'LL FINISH UP
ON THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR
THANK YOU ANYONE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. BEGIN AGAIN A PAIR
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE WILL GO TO A LINE OF
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS MICHELLE DAUBER I'M A
PROFESSOR OF LAW CAN FOR LAW
SCHOOL- I SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
I WOULD LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY
POINT OUT THAT RATE- WHEN IT IS
ON A DRAFT HAS HIGH COSTS BOTH
THE SOCIETY AND VICTIMS- BUT
I'LL- THANK YOU. WE'RE JUST
TAKING PEOPLE'S NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND- A THIRD
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION THE BILL
ALREADY HAS A MOTION AND A
SECOND OF THE DAY ANYMORE
COLORS- I'M SURE THERE IS NO
MORE CALLERS IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THAT'S WONDERFUL
BRING IT BACK I SEE NO COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY OFFER MY VOTE.
THANK YOU TAKE IT OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. AND THAT CONCLUDES THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.